(audience cheering)
- I'm gonna lead.
I'm gonna lead.
There's a lot of fans here.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- I'm gonna lead,
I don't know if y'all saw "That's My Jam"
with miss over here.
- [Kate] Oh my god.
But I was like, we're competitive.
- [Kate] Yeah, oh yeah.
- [Kelly] But I love that.
I'm very competitive.
- Well, I'm, see, I kind
of, am I competitive?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Oh, no, yeah.
The person that asks that
is totally competitive.
- She's the one who is screaming
at game nights and stuff.
I mean, she's the one
who's like, I'm like, Kate,
It's a game night, we're
supposed have a good time.
- And I'm like, "Shut up"
- I know.
- So Oliver-
- Accusations of cheating all the time.
- After, the Jimmy Fallon
thing I literally called Ollie,
I'm like, was I nuts?
Like was I, did I come
across like too competitive?
- This is exactly what I asked my friends
about me when I was on the show.
I was like do I come across as insane?
- Is it weird?
Yeah, because something happens.
- [Kelly] Yeah, me too.
- And I'm just like,
get me in it, you know,
and its like takes you over completely.
- Yes!
But why play unless you're gonna compete?
- That's what I say.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Look at him, he's out.
- You show up to win.
Not in like it's the end of the world.
- No, I get it, I get
it, I get it, I get it.
Kate's had game nights forever, right.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, first of all, I never get invited.
- Wait, is that because-
- Which is true.
Yeah because I'm not a
big enough celebrity,
is what I think.
(everyone laughing)
I really do because-
- That's not true.
- Is this because you're
not competitive enough?
- No, no, no, no, it's because I have fear
when I'm going up
against like Leo Decaprio
and Tom Hanks and you know.
- Oliver, that's ridiculous.
- No, it's true.
Like Sir Anthony Hopkins
is doing, running charades.
- I would never wanna play
charades in that company.
- I would give anything
for Sir Anthony Hopkins
to do running charades.
- I'm serious in that like I
have anxiety for game nights
because she invites very prominent people
who are professionals-
- No, no stop.
- And academy award winners.
- So here's the thing.
- I wouldn't go either.
- The truth is that I used to invite him
and he never showed up.
- No.
- So then I just stopped inviting him.
- Because he'd never, well, first of all
your wife is always so late.
- I know.
- The party would be like done.
(crowd shouting)
- I know
- It's true, Erinn, you're
like, it's the kid's birthday,
its 5:30, and like,
literally it's like 8:00 PM.
I'm like, Erin?
Are you?
Where are the kids?
- She's like, no, no, we're
in the car, we're in the car.
- Those are people.
That's a thing.
Like some people don't do
well at time management.
What?
- [Oliver] No, I know.
- I'm not late for a game night and-
- And you're not late for like a gig.
- No, no, no, I'm not late for like a gig.
No, I would never.
Those people that wait, I
don't know why fans do that.
Like three hours later,
the artist gets on stage.
- No, it's terrible.
- I'm at like waffle house by then.
I'm like gone by then.
- Now I want to have
a game night with you.
- Oh my.
I don't know if you do.
- [Kate] You have to do it
- I get crazy.
Here's the thing, I'm not a sore loser.
That's not it.
I don't care if I lose
but I don't want to play with people
that don't want to compete.
- I get that.
I get that of course.
- And then they make you feel
bad that you're competitive-
- Yeah but when it's like Christmas Eve
and we're playing game out with the family
and all of a sudden everyone's
screaming at each other,
like you cheated
and of course, mom has left
the room 30 minutes ago.
She's like, I'm not
dealing with any of this.
She's gone.
- You can see mom's face when
we all decide to play a game.
It's like-
- [Kelly] That's my mother.
- Yeah, it's like, no.
- My mother cannot stand it
because me and my sister are like,
we don't play with cheaters either.
You are kicked out.
We actually, my sister and I on tour
we didn't allow Dennis, our tour manager,
to play Yatzy with us again.
- [Kate] Because he cheats?
- No, because he didn't get excited
about his freaking Yatzy.
(audience laughs)
He got a Yatzy and he just was like,
he literally went, oh Yatzy.
And I was like-
- [Kate] No, no.
- I was like wait, what?
He got kicked off the bus.
- The word is designed
for you to scream it.
Like Yatzy!
- It's exciting.
- Oh, Yatzy is the best.
- Wait, what's your game name?
Because I like code names,
what's like your game of choice?
- Well, game night is usually Mafia.
Do you know Mafia?
- No.
- It's like, woo.
It's like Werewolves and Villagers.
- It's great, everyone
ends up dead at the end.
(everyone laughs)
- Well, pretty much.
Pretty much.
Except Tom Hanks.
- Yeah, he always wins.
- Tom Hanks, nobody
wants to kill Tom Hanks.
- No, you're right.
This is weird.
- I'm not kidding.
- No, no, no.
So Mafia, is a game that was,
the English version is called
Werewolves and Villagers.
And it was apparently, I
could be totally wrong,
created by the MI6 to see how
sociopathic you are at lying,
right?
It's basically like if
you can convince somebody
and lie that well then
you're on like a good path
to being a spy, you know, and-
- Wow, see you play with a lot of actors,
this must be hard.
- I wasn't joking.
- [Kelly] You weren't.
- No, I'm intimidated.
All of a sudden Leo is
looking at me, he's like.
I'm like.
(everyone laughs)
What do I do?
- [Kelly] Freaking out.
- And I'm like Tom Hanks, what do I do?
- It's an audition you don't wanna fail.
(everyone laughs)
I will always be busy
if you ever invite me.
I'm terrified of that.
Like around actors.
- Oh, no, it's so much fun.
It really is so much fun.
And the thing, the only, I would
never do it with a partner.
I think it's broken up
most of my partnerships.
(everyone laughs)
How did you kill me?
I can't believe you just killed me.
- [Kelly] I am you, playing the game.
- Yeah, and then, you
know, you're in a game.
It's like, if they're
doing something wrong
and even if you're on the same team
and you know you have to kill them,
you're like, I gotta kill
my, I gotta kill them.
- Oh yeah.
- And it's over, it's like,
it really gets personal.
That's happened a couple
times at game night.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah like people have left early.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
I don't do well with
subjective games and crowds.
Like with who we're playing
games with is subjective.
- You'll be great.
And you'll be loud I can tell.
- I know.
- It would happen.
It would just all of a sudden
like halfway through, you'd
be like, I know you are mafia.
- Like, wait, here's a good
example of how I play games.
So I did Hollywood game night
and Isla Fisher was on my team
and this is how crazy I get.
She literally being a girl's
girl, like leaned over to me
and she was like, hey, just let you know,
like maybe you wanna
like, not drink anymore.
And I was like, oh, I.
(everyone laughs)
This is not alcohol man.
I literally, we were on camera,
so I was like fake drinking, I
was like not really drinking.
And I was like, oh, this
is just like, who I am.
I was like, this is not alcohol.
- You're like, so we're not friends.
- I was like she thinks I'm too much,
I am, but I like playing games.
Anyway and that's about
me and my craziness.